yeah because like i remember like uh you
know because february just passed and
like i love watching like the sumo
yeah and the sumo season is like during
the winter yeah so just finished but
like of course because it's a pandemic
you can't have people in this tiny you
know stadium
watching the summer so like yeah it was
really sad to see
this like massive sumo stadium only
having maybe like
four people in it yeah and it's just
like and you know obviously after every
win right usually the crowd you know
like claps or like cheers or something
but instead it's like someone does this
like epic win
yeah and like three people are clapping
it just sounds like a cow [ __ ] it just
feels like there's zero stakes
yeah you can't if you can't hear
anything it's not hype at all yeah that
was really interesting cause the sumo
they were like all wearing mash before
they got yeah
it's on stage seeing them like all right
we have these precautions they take
their masks off they step up and
immediately just
[ __ ] put their faces together i'm
like yeah i don't know i don't know
about this
there's not so much point i don't know
how socially distant sumoing is but i
mean
it is funny how crowds can play into
sporting event hype because i
so i've been recommended a lot of like
since we did the chess tournament i've
been
like been recommended way more chess
clips and been watching like chess
streamers like
hikaru and everything like that and
there's just
like there's just something about the
image i had about chess before that was
boring
and i feel a big part of that was just
how bored everyone looks in any big
chess
crowd right it's it's like it's like
people playing a chess tournament during
a coughing
coughing event yeah and and what i've
what i realized
i like one thing i've realized about how
we could like how the the image could be
easily changed was i was recommending
this
other events like clips of this other
event where it's just a bunch of grand
masters
um who went to who are just like chewing
[ __ ]
uh shooting [ __ ] and having fun and they
were like having team tournaments and
just like
and like trash talking each other and
i'm just like dude this seems like a
legit fun event
and this this could have easily changed
the image
of chess which i think it's it's great
now that the image
of chess is being like slowly changed
you know i know
not everyone will agree with you going
down i mean that's that's my opinion as
a filthy casual chess player
some chess gm tweeted out being like man
it's such a shame
that chess is going in this direction
yeah and then everyone's just like
in like a not serious direction yeah
yeah because you know chess has a lot of
history behind it and there's a lot of
people who are like it's it's
you know it's it's big brain it's
intelligent and it's being watered down
for these common folk you know
yes i mean you are like an ex you know
you've played chess
yeah i mean for your country how do you
feel about it i mean it doesn't really
seem like you had that like purest view
on it yeah
no because like i hated it because like
when i was doing it it was a bunch of
you know 60 year old white men who would
just be in charge of everything
and they talked about it like you were
like the [ __ ] night's god
yeah yeah culture like yeah because you
know it's taken very seriously in the uk
and the history behind it is like very
long and you know what not but
you know i don't give a [ __ ] i mean you
know if the sports
you know wants to have more funding and
be more popular i think it's good thing
people get into chess i mean
yeah it's a good game i think that it's
you know one of the
probably the better better games your
kid can get into yeah um
i mean it's going to evolve together
with the times right and curious always
behind you know i mean you know
unfortunately chess is
probably on its own a bit boring yeah
let's be honest right like i play it
i i you know say that but i think you
know adding these tournaments that
don't really take away anything from the
pro scene you know if it gets you know
if you look at chess viewership on
twitch you know outside of like
pogchamps and stuff like that
the big chess streamers viewership has
grown a lot i mean
how many street how many viewers does
hikari get now it's [ __ ]
25k yeah and it's it's [ __ ] great
because before you literally could not
make money
pla like playing there's so many big
chat streamers now yeah and it's really
epic
you know epic wow that's really easy
that's coming up
it's pretty epic seeing uh that like you
know there's room for
like many chess streamers to make a
living off this and stream it and you
know
i mean it makes sense right like i mean
it it's really taught me how important
images yeah in regards to like a sport
and stuff like that because yes you know
there's there's
there's you know you got to respect the
legacy and the history and
and stuff like that but you get to a
point where it's modernized yeah it
needs to modernize they need to catch up
with the times and
i've it's great because i've gotten way
more into chess
simply because it just it just looks
funner yeah you know
it looks way more fun and i mean there's
like like
stuff like you know everyone thinks that
sports like rules don't change
yeah like rules are like sacred but like
stuff like basketball i'm pretty sure
the nba changes the rule
have changed the rules a few times based
on what makes a
more fun viewing experience yeah yeah so
it begs to question is like what's more
important the sport
or the audience yeah and so i think
chess is out there for crossroads where
there's obviously people who have been
training their whole life to be
you know pros and whatnot yeah and
obviously yet sucks that maybe your
sport is a little less serious
but on the other hand you have way more
opportunities way more money
you know way more chance to have a
platform and do whatever you want and if
you want to
be on the sidelines being salty about it
you're probably going to be the one left
behind yeah
it's it's a balance at the end of the
day right yeah you can't go too far in
either direction
yeah i feel that like i remember when
hikari got signed up for tsm
i was just like holy [ __ ] that's pretty
cool this this is a pogba
that is a podcast
like like just just like imagine imagine
if we had a chess tournament where
people showed up in like esports gowns
you know
in [ __ ] esports shirts and stuff like
that that that would be pretty high for
my opinion but obviously i'm a filthy
casual
don't play i don't play chess out of
anything but just casually so
that's just my opinion i totally forgot
i played in chess tournament like last
week
i totally forgot i did that oh yeah yeah
oh yeah
yeah it was fine i mean i had like one
hour sleep so it's pretty brutal and i
had to film
like i had to go somewhere i mean you
say that but you're like no knowing your
schedule i kind of like
i was like kind of you were you're
addicted to apex back then
yeah yeah yeah you kind of did it to
yourself yeah yeah yeah yeah i did it
you know
i did i just you know you just say yes
to something and you're like you don't
really think about like how it will like
actually fit into your schedule because
it just sounds cool until it happens
yeah so i got invited to twitch rivals
which was like they wanted to do like a
chess tournament where
you get paired with like a gm or
something and they tell you which piece
to move
and you have to choose which of that
piece if they say porn
you choose which of the eight pawns to
move right and so it's pretty fun
i mean yeah i haven't played chess like
since our tournament yeah so i was
pretty rusty and obviously
not having much sleep and so yeah but it
was good fun i like doing it it's fun i
like playing chess but it's really
annoying how like there's some comments
as well that like bro connor wasn't a
connor didn't play like when he was a
kid that's a lie he's so [ __ ] now and
i'm like
bro if you didn't play for like seven
years and you played now i bet you
probably wouldn't you ever heard of it
you ever heard of a gap
yeah yeah and also i think i'm probably
like the same level or probably better
as a child than i am now yeah
yeah which could be weird to say i mean
like yeah i mean i mean
it's the same logic oh you learned the
quadratic equation during school and you
can't do it now you didn't learn it
yeah it's also like people think like
you know how good do you think that like
12 11 year olds are at this game like
yeah
i mean i yeah there are some exceptions
of amazing
characters there's only so many magnus
castles right yeah yeah yeah yeah
and i was like bro i was like the worst
on my team yeah i just sneaked in
like i remember when i was talking about
you know my uh
my masters and i was like explain to you
guys i couldn't remember what
equation i was talking about it was
second order differential equations i
remember that now and i and
connor says is it integer you're
thinking of and i guess i was like
yeah i guess there was i think i should
know too as well i also have
yeah there was so many comments being
like god's whatever
god didn't pass his masters can't even
remember that jesus christ
if you don't use something surprisingly
you forget it yeah you also have to
understand that a lot of times during
this podcast a lot of us are just brain
dead
we're just we're just chatting it's just
like again you know it's the whole vibe
of the show
we just talk we don't really plan
anything none of the topics ever planned
beforehand we just
we just kind of shoot the [ __ ] you know
we didn't plan to go in the [ __ ]
masters talk of engineering
like i i'm sure if i applied for an
engineering job i'm more qualified than
someone who is like hasn't got the
degree but might be studying that thing
yeah who probably knows more than me at
this current time but because i haven't
done anything
yeah like three years exactly [ __ ] i
don't know i mean you forget
you forget it i forgot everything i did
i finally understand i barely knew it at
the time yeah
that's the thing i feel like now i
finally understand how like
my parents felt when i was like going to
them and being like can you help me with
this math equation it's like you you
finished school right you've done this
before
and my parents are like uh i i don't
know how to do this i'm like what do you
mean you don't know how to do it
you did this in school i think i can't
even remember like having passed my
masters in engineering i probably can't
remember how to do basic trigonometry
now
if someone came if like some
ten-year-old came up to me and was like
can you help me solve this long division
equation i'd be like [ __ ] so far
like i totally get that now yeah because
i remember
as a kid you're just like how can you
not know this you're an adult
you know everything you learned this
before you know how like you see those
[ __ ] like
facebook quizzes that pop up that are
like you know it'll be like
different tanks of water and it'll be
like which one will fill up first
but that was like literally like part of
my fluids exam we had stuff like that
and i'm like back in the day i'm sure i
can answer that too but right now i got
no [ __ ] idea
because i don't remember what the [ __ ]
it was all about